(audience clapping)
- Seat.
- Hi.
- Hello. Meet Angela.
- Yes. Hi.
- Yes. Hi there.
- What an honor. Oh my gosh.
I am star-struck.
(Angela laughing)
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh. I'm so excited.
You were just here like before,
Quantum Leap was just coming out,
now it's so huge now, congratulations.
- Thank you so much.
(audience cheering)
Thank you, thank you.
It's really nice. It's really nice. Yeah.
- [Kelly] It's awesome to
be doing something you love
and to be successful.
- Yeah.
(kelly makes trumpet noises)
Yeah, I mean, I am
living my dream right now
and I'm very, very happy.
I feel like I'm in the flow of things.
It's all good. It's great. Thank you.
- [Kelly] Oh, I love that.
- Thank you.
- I also hear that you're
now of a very exclusive club.
I wanna get this right.
It's in Hollywood, it's called TCT
- [Raymond] That's right.
- T C C C.
- Um-hmm.
- [Kelly] What is that? What is that?
How do I get in?
- The first two letters are Tom Cruise.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- And the other letters are coconut cake.
- [Kelly] Coconut cake.
- Is it coconut or Christmas?
- [Angela] I think it's Christmas cake
- Is it a Christmas cake?
- Oh, Christmas cake?
- TCCC.
(all laughing)
- Wait, wait.
Did you get a cake too?
- [Angela] I get a cake.
- You've got a cake.
- [Raymond] I get a cake, you get a cake.
- I didn't get a cake.
I like cake, Tom Cruise.
(everyone laughing)
I like cake.
Is it the most delicious cake ever?
- [Raymond] It's the most delicious cake.
It's up to the standard
of Tom Cruise standards.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- It's a coconut cake.
- My mouth is watering.
- It's so good.
I've had it dipped in resin
and I've had it preserved
on my house, cause one day I'll eat it,
but yeah, I've heard it's great.
No, it's so amazing.
- It's so good that at
our 25th anniversary,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- We had the cake.
We had a three tiered TCC-CCC cake.
(all laughing)
- Oh wow.
- [Angela] And I ate the
second tier all by myself.
- [Kelly] What's this cake?
(all laughing)
- Was it delivered to you in the same way
it was delivered to me
because on Christmas Eve there
was just a knock on my door
and I was really close to the door,
so I was only maybe about
three seconds away from it,
I opened, there was no one there.
And then I looked down and
there was just a pink box.
- [Kelly] Hoo.
- [Raymond] And it says-
- [Angela] Yep. That's it.
- [Raymond] It says warmest wishes to you
this holiday season, Tom Cruise.
- [Kelly] What?
- [Raymond] Yeah.
(audience clapping)
And it was like, it was
as if he dropped by like,
on a jet pack and just flew away.
- You know what, it's
Tom Cruise, maybe he did.
- Yeah, I mean, I, believe it.
- I feel like he'd try it.
(both guests laughing)
I feel like he'd be like,
I'll try, let's do it. Yeah.
(Raymond laughing)
I feel like he's that guy, right?
Mission impossible.
- [Raymond] That's right.
- He can try any of those things.
- I actually wanna try a
jet pack and eat the cake.
Whatever, Tom.
(guest laughing)
So you were here before talking about,
it was before Quantum Leap premiered,
so did you know, did you
think it would be a success?
- You know, it's hard to know
if anything you're working
on is gonna be great.
You read the scripts and you
go, "Okay, this is great."
And then you do the days and you go,
"Okay, that was a great scene."
And then you just take it a scene
at a time and it feels good.
The ensemble's good, the scripts are good,
the producers are good.
Everyone's saying it's great.
And then it goes up and then
you hope people watch it
and then people watch it
and then you realize it's
something that people
are gravitating towards and
you go, "Oh, thank God."
You know, what a relief.
- Well, I think it's so interesting
cause y'all put a lot in other
people's hands as actors.
Cause like, as a musician,
I'm there for the whole
process of this song.
Like, you see every version of
it right, before it goes out.
But as actors, like,
sometimes you only see
the clips that you're in.
You don't see it all together.
So then, it's hard to know, probably.
- It's impossible to know.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You go in and you do,
- It's a lot of trust tree going on there.
- Absolutely. It takes a village.
And we wouldn't be able to do anything
without our crew, our incredible crew.
So, they're working harder than I am.
- [Kelly] Oh man, yeah.
- So yeah, it's incredible.
- [Kelly] I think every crew
on every show works harder
than everybody else.
Their always the first ones there,
the last ones to breakdown.
- That's right. That's right.
- [Kelly] Same thing in
the musician world, yeah.
- Well, the fall finale of
Quantum Leap airs tonight
at 10 on NBC and be sure to catch
up on the entire season
streaming on Peacock.